human beings addicted to dozens of
substances to behaviors I mean all kinds
of things guy goes out in the morning to
pick up his paper off his porch and it's
not there and he has a heart attack and
I guessed it my god
you know what am I going to and he has
to have instant relief from the
traumatic crisis of the non presence of
the morning information fix and and the
phenomenon of falling in love which
doesn't really happen with other animals
I mean other animals bond but they don't
go bananas in the way that we do on on
this issue we're we're chemically highly
cued in a way that a lot of animals
around us aren't so then history because
of this because of this addictive drive
within us that we have because of this
disrupted symbiotic relationship in
prehistory see we're looking for the
score but we can't quite find it
imperialism doesn't do it heroin doesn't
do it
sadomasochism doesn't do it nothing
quite does it but we keep trying stuff
cocaine money fascism mercantilism
ideology all of this stuff we are very
very restless and the path of our
Restless frantic peregrinations across
the intellectual landscape is what we
call history
you know it's our effort to try and get
straight yep back to something which we
feel we deserve and that we lost and we
don't know quite what it was well
meanwhile in the rain forests in the
Arctic tundra these little brown people
have been keeping the nosis going never
questioning never doubting the millennia
after millennia going into these
hyperdimensional mud spaces and
operators there while this has been
going on we have been elaborating
positivism scientific philosophy
building atom smashers so forth and so
on we have created them out of our
infantile cultural style what Erich
Fromm would call a fecal cultural style
because we just excrete stuff all kinds
of stuff
they have held this mystery but they to
my mind the mistake that has been made
is that it's been thought that they
understood it
that we now go to the shamans and they
will explain to us what the inner skinny
is on all this that isn't it there's no
explaining this once you've been there
you know the futility of a notion like
understanding the psychedelic experience
it's like understanding the ocean or
understand planetary ecology we think
that things are to be understood but
some things are simply to be what's the
word appreciated imbibe to be in the
darshan
[Music]